now an update on the latest medical
developments related to the pandemic
here to discuss them once again CBS News
medical contributor dr. David agus who
joins us from Los Angeles dr. good
morning 250 million Americans now
impacted by these social distancing
guidelines how long will it be before we
understand or realize how effective
these guidelines have been you know
there's a delay obviously there's an
incubation period of the virus two to
nine days and then the virus itself has
a course of several weeks testing in the
United States still isn't where we need
to have it in the big cities and so we
look at hospitalization rates and I
think they're going or they should start
to level off over the next week or so in
many of the major affected cities now
worried about are the next wave cities
that were alluded to earlier in the show
and then again there'll be a lag between
intervention when we all stay inside
social distance too when we see an
effect on the virus doctor there's been
a shift in the guidance on wearing masks
as we've talked about here on this
broadcast what what should people know
right now about covering their faces in
public they need to know they have to do
it I mean this is something that's
imperative when you breathe on a mirror
those are droplets and if you go outside
and you're asymptomatic and member
people are asymptomatic before they get
symptoms before the virus and there also
can be excited the whole course of the
virus you breathe those droplets can
spread you wear a homemade mask of cloth
you can stop that and save other people
and shorten the duration of the virus in
this country we all have to play our
part you know that is one of the ways
dr. agus that you can help prevent the
spread and we're learning that about 25
percent of the people who are spreading
this may be asymptomatic right now that
have the corona virus how's that
affecting how we are approaching
treating and going after this disease
well I mean that unfortunately is the
difficult part with this virus is some
people have minimal to no symptoms at
all and they're contagious and when they
go out they don't mean it because they
don't think they're sick but they go
shopping they stop and talk to somebody
that can spread the virus and that it
keeps spreading if the virus keeps
spreading
our period of being inside will be
prolonged we really all have to work
together on this and I know it seems
overkill but everybody needs to stay
inside and when you do go out for
necessities please wear a mask one of
the things that we've talked about with
you throughout the weeks is the idea of
treatments and the approach to this
technology is playing a role what can
you tell us about where we are in
regards to that right now well yesterday
was a big step up the Secretary of
Health Human Services azar announced
that a new database put together by
Oracle was launched and every doctor in
the country will register a patient now
before starting treatment and then if
the patient's outpatient he or she we
get an email every day and be able to
update what's going on with their
treatments so we will know what drugs
work well when to use them and who to
use them in given time I mean it's very
exciting that we're gonna collect a tin
every patient will be part of the cure
and we're all going to help together the
data that website for this is kovin 19
oracle.com
every doctor please go there and
register before you read through your
put patients on medications because we
have to learn from every experience so
we can all get better we have to be
patient as well seems to be the lesson
for all of us in this dr. David agus
thank you very much